le peuple américain dont nous avons besoin d'un champion pour lui
rappeler de quoi il est capable
qui avons-nous ici Je suis Jesse Owens tu
veux gagner une médaille d'or
continue à Berlin comment peux-tu justifier de
participer en Allemagne alors qu'il y a
tant de discrimination  ici à la maison maintenant,
ce que vous les garçons pensez que vous allez faire
dans les douches pas avant que nous ayons fini,
vous n'êtes pas seulement vous avez une chance de porter
un coup puissant sous le
régime hitlérien, nous ne devons pas aller à ces
jeux olympiques pour  montrons notre solidarité avec les
opprimés du peuple allemand
tu auras la chance de faire partie de l'
histoire et tu
vas t'en éloigner  ce n'était pas nécessaire que
les gens comptent sur vous
pour aller là-bas à Berlin et battre
ces nazis qu'il a été mis ici pour acheter n'écoutez pas
rien n'a d'importance pas la couleur pas l'argent pas
même l'homme le plus rapide sur terre
pendant ces 10 secondes  à une gratuité totale